hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute wieder ein kleines
schwangerschafts update machen ich habe
euch auf instagram und auf facebook
gefragt was sie denn wieder aktuell für
fragen habt und die möchte ich euch
jetzt beantworten also erstmal ganz
aktuell ich bin jetzt in der 37
schwangerschaftswoche
das heißt ich habe jetzt nur noch drei
wochen und sechs tage bis zum
entbindungstermin und es ist echt nicht
mehr lange und aktuell weg ich jetzt
sage und schreibe 77 kilo also habe ich
ungefähr 17 kilo schon zugenommen
ich weiß zwar selber nicht genau wie das
geht aber also ich finde ich bin zwar
schon schwerer geworden aber das ist
wirklich 17 kilo sind da bin ich selber
ehrlich sagt bisschen überrascht und
habe auch jetzt karten aktuellen
bauchumfang von 1 meter 17
keine ahnung aber ist echt komisch weil
die kleine in meinem bauch die wiegt
jetzt ungefähr 2600 gramm dass kamerun
rascher gerät ganz gut eben abmessen und
ja der rest bin wahrscheinlich in die
große größer weil es ja auch schon die
größe weiß ich ich glaub's x 44 cm
so ungefähr alles wird auf jeden fall
ziemlich eng in meinem bauch und ich bin
ganz froh dass es jetzt doch nur noch
vier wochen sind und ich dann bald
geschafft habe und bald die kleine maus
hoffentlich gesund in unseren armen
liegt ja auf jeden fall wurde ich
gefragt was hast du denn aktuell hast du
beschwerden
mittlerweile habe ich beschwerden also
es jetzt nicht mehr alles so einfach wie
noch vor einigen wochen
hier wird es zb vermehrt abends oder
auch so am nachmittag immer sodbrennen
was ziemlich ätzend ist also im wahrsten
sinne des wortes weil einfach dass das
brennt total in der speiseröhre und vor
allem bin ich dann nachts im bett liegt
und schlafen möchte dann brennt einfach
alles und meistens muss ich mich dann
entweder fast hinsetzen zum schlafen
oder ich steht dann auf und trinken glas
mädels das hilft ab und zu das habe ich
gestern gemacht und dann geht's auch
wieder
aber wenn es jetzt zu arg wird dann muss
ich glaube ich doch noch mal zum arzt er
hat mir zwar schon was verschrieben aber
ich gucke mir das dann erst noch mal an
aber im moment geht es halt ganz einfach
oder medikamente
und mit ein bisschen mädels und ich habe
den tipp bekommen hassen müsse zug und
ist anscheinend auch gut helfen das
problem vielleicht heute nacht aus das
verwirrt mich wenn du gar nicht reden
ich kann nicht ich muss es mir immer
verkneifen
verheiratet seit sieben jahren du hast
eine beschwerde geheiratet
ja und sonst habe ich halt im rücken
weiterhin probleme dass ich halt bei
langem stehen rückenschmerzen bekommen
und mir fällt hat mittlerweile echt
schwer gemütlich zu sitzen oder
gemütlich zu liegen also eigentlich kann
ich nur noch so sitzen hinten angelehnt
aber das sieht jetzt glaube ich diesen
unvorteilhaft aus deswegen versuche ich
jetzt so biografie afrika ich setze mich
nach hinten und im auto ist halt
ziemlich unbequem aber ich meine es ist
ja nicht mehr lange und das sind
wirklich ganz normale beschreiben die
glaube ich jede schwangere in den
letzten vier wochen hat ich wurde dann
auch gefragt zelle wie geht's dir
eigentlich nach der cache volt in wien
also ich hab so echt noch gemacht ich
war echt noch auf der paperworld und ihr
bekommt da auch ganz bald ein video dazu
haben nämlich ein bisschen was mit
gefilmt aber es war für mich halt
wirklich sehr anstrengend am ersten tag
habe ich noch ein bisschen was gekocht
und vorgeführt und hab mich dann
hingesetzt und mit euch fotos gemacht
und ein bisschen autogramme geschrieben
aber ich habe dann schon am zweiten tag
gemerkt okay das kann ich nicht mehr
machen also du kannst nicht den ganzen
tag da stehen und kochen und backen
deswegen habe ich samstags dann glaube
ich nur ganz kurz was gebacken und
sonntags war irgendwie wieder fit habe
wieder ein bisschen mehr gemacht und es
muss aber im großen und ganzen was
wirklich sehr anstrengend für mich aber
auch sehr schön weil ich eben ganz viele
zuschauer getroffen habe viele kinder
viele erwachsene und ich würde auf jeden
fall wieder machen auch wieder schwanger
aber ich denke es war so jetzt gerade
noch so im rahmen also jetzt auf die
hannover messe kann ich natürlich nicht
gehen weil die jetzt in zweieinhalb
wochen erst wer und das geht absolut
nicht mehr also jetzt zu den jetzigen
zeit
und hätte ich niemals mehr auf eine
messe gehen können weil es einfach viel
zu anstrengend war ehrlich ich war ja
also ich hab mir die meisten shows thema
eigenschaft diesem monat hat gut
übernommen also muss ich schon sagen es
recht gut gemerkt da muss ich echt lobe
ich überlege gerade nach hannover
es geht natürlich nicht alleine gestellt
dann wurde ich gefragt wo kaufst du
eigentlich eine schwangerschaft kleidung
also eine ganz lange zeit habe ich gar
keine schwangerschafts kleidung
gebraucht das braucht man wirklich erst
so gegen ende weil dann einfach nichts
mehr passt ich habe da zum beispiel den
tipp wenn man noch gut in seiner alten
hosen reinkommt kann vorne einfach die
hose auf lassen und so ein kleines gummi
rein machen dass es halt nicht runter
rutscht so habe ich das am anfang
gemacht und dann habe ich mir online ein
paar sachen bestellt aber nicht so viele
weil ich bin ja nicht ewig schwanger und
ich finde es dann immer das ist so eine
kleine verschwendung und mutzel
überflüssig wenn man da zu viel hat und
habe zum beispiel auch tagsüber einfach
t shirts von murat an
das heißt ich habe keinen bauchumfang
115 ich bin 17
ja und ich habe mir zwar ein paar
kleider jetzt auch gekauft aber dann
halt auch so gekauft dass ich sie jetzt
auch nach der geburt noch ansehen kann
vor allem zum stillen also meistens dann
so still kombinationen still und
umstandsmode und diesen halt ganz
praktisch ich glaube ich habe vielleicht
vier kleider oder so und ansonsten habe
ich also basics ebenso text so blöd
ausgehalten figuren drauf sie ja in der
türkei habe ich zum beispiel im frühjahr
bisserl was mitgenommen so ein paar
t-shirts aber ansonsten kommt man da gar
nichts kaufen weil da immer so comic
figuren drauf sind wo draufsteht babys
loading oder keine ahnung einem coming
oder immer lass mich raus das finde ich
dann halt ja kann ich fragen nicht halt
eher neutrale sachen und ansonsten habe
ich ganz einfache tanktops im moment an
und sie hat eine ganz normale weste oder
bluse drüber und lasse halt offen und
mir schon eingefallen ich kann meine
karohemden eigentlich auch wieder
anziehen weil die kann ich einfach offen
lassen
hallo verstimmt besonders auffällige
farbe bekennen
der ist eigentlich weg geräumt aber
jetzt muss ich so wiederholen weil ihr
jetzt schon ziemlich kalt draußen und
wenn es so weitergeht muss ich leider
auch eine jacke von borat tragen weil
ich habe immer zu sagen verloren daher
vor meiner mama letztmalig eine von
meiner mama und weil ich einfach mir
keine umstand jacke kaufen möchte na ja
eine ganz lustige frage weißt du schon
ob das baby früher oder später kommen
wird keine ahnung also es hat auch schon
jemand gefragt kann sie dir nicht am
28.10 kommen ich kann es selber nicht
beeinflussen also sie kommt einfach wann
sie möchte ich denke dass sie vor meinem
termin kommt also fort am 21 oktober
weil ich einfach merkel wie schwer das
schon wird und wie es drückt und ich
auch schon so leichtes ziehen habe aber
ganz genau kann ich natürlich nicht
sagen weil ich eine natürliche geburt
möchte und keinen geplanten
kaiserschnitt
von daher auch der arzt ist auch der
arzt der hatte zwei tage vor termin und
jetzt hat meine schwestern whatsapp
gruppe eingerichtet wo die ganze familie
mit drin steckt und alle geben gegen
diese ihre tipps ab murat hat gesagt
hauptsache es kommt so ist es dann wurde
ich gefragt hast du schon eine klinik
tasche gepackt was ist deine erste
ausstattung und ist dein kinderwagen
schon da und da muss ich sagen das mache
ich in einem separaten video das würde
ich dann nächste woche mal drehen wenn
ich ein bisschen zeit habe und da euch
einfach einzelne videos machen sind
sprengt es immer so eine schwangerschaft
ab date und ich versuche auch heute
bittl das ganze zu kürzen
wie heißt das video was ist in einer
klinik tasche was sind meine klinik
tasche ansprechen sowie der klinik
tasche ist es so ich finde es auch immer
ganz cool als tipp vor allem für frauen
die zum ersten mal schwanger sind dass
man einfach weiß was traurig und was
brauche ich nicht also ich kann euch
dann auch den vergleich zum ersten mal
sagen was hatte ich beim ersten mal
beide samira dabei was war überflüssig
was hat gefehlt und was nämlich dieses
mal mit also das kann ich euch dann so
als tipp mit geben wo wir zamira während
der geburt sein das hatte ich letztes
jahr schon angesprochen wenn ich mich
nicht irre
das emirat einfach bei meinen eltern
sein und dem rat wird mehr zurückgebucht
begleitung
ganz einfach so ok ich hoffe dass wir
dann gleich die nächste frage murat gilt
eigentlich auch an dich wirst du
elternzeit nehmen
ja es ist deshalb ziemlich schwer ich
mein ich arbeite die baubranche also und
hätte mich fertiggemacht gerne als
manche eltern bleibt nicht so ganz
extrem wenn es so typische männerberufe
sind und wissen hat natürlich alles
harte kerle hätte mich eingeschlossen
aber die härtesten kerle haben das
weichste herz finde ich aber auf jeden
fall ist wird schnell aufgezogen haben
weiß aber du bist ein echter mann wenn
du für deine frau und für dein kind darf
ich also eltern seid ja vielleicht kommt
man ja schon irgendwie natürlich nicht
den mutterschutz kriegsspiel unten auf
die guten zuviel ja auf jeden fall kann
ich euch da als tipp mit geben das habe
ich jetzt vom von der ersten
schwangerschaft auf jeden fall gelernt
und daraus gelernt
ich hatte bei der samira kindergeld und
elterngeld und so weiter erst nach der
geburt alles beantragten asyl geht
natürlich auch erst nach der geburt aber
ihr könnt zum beispiel schon während der
schwangerschaft so in den letzten wochen
wenn die zeit für euch habt einfach
schon mal alle papiere ausfüllen und
liegen lassen und wenn ihr dann vom
krankenhaus wieder da seid einfach die
geburtsurkunde mit einpacken und dann
könnte das einfach alles abschicken
weil für mich war das letztes mal
ziemlicher stress nach der geburt dann
noch an das alles zu denken und dann
muss man sich darum kümmern weil es muss
er geld reinkommen und das ist einfach
alles vorher schon erledigt habt und
danach können das einfach abschicken
also es ist echt super tipp ich bin ein
fuchs also ich hab das schon vorher
gemacht ich habe es auch schon für
street- und für die kinder beantragt
david kommen wir zur frage wie das noch
weitere kinder also eigentlich natürlich
schon
ich kann im moment noch nichts sagen
aber ich kann es mir gut 34
murat das hatte man letztmals schon dann
die frage ist das zimmer schon
eingerichtet
ich habe ehrlich sagt bis heute noch
nicht eingerichtet weil ich hatte
einfach bis diese woche noch ziemlich
viel zu tun und kann mir jetzt ab
nächster woche bisserl zeit nehmen und
da kann eigentlich auch direkt aufs
thema zu sprechen kommen
mit den videos was in diesen traurigen
musik beispiel auf jeden fall also ich
habe es bisher geschafft immer drei
videos die woche zu veröffentlichen drei
rezepte und ich denke da müssen jetzt
einfach ein bisschen runterschrauben
es macht mir zwar weiterhin spaß aber es
ist wirklich sehr anstrengend für mich
geworden
videos zu drehen vor allem muss wir
betonen ja auf ihn war es ist wirklich
sehr anstrengend geworden und ich denke
vielleicht nächste woche noch 12 videos
drehen und ansonsten schaue ich einfach
dass ich so zwei videos noch die woche
hochladen
vielleicht ist auch mal nur eins aber
ich hab schon vorgeschlagen das dann dem
rat einfach übernimmt 50 sie halbiert
nein also ich jetzt sagen dem rad über
nimmt dann einfach macht auch mal ein
rezept wenn es mir halt nicht so gut
geht und ich denke nächste woche ist die
grenze dann danach werde ich
wahrscheinlich keine rezept videos mit
drehen und kann mich einfach ein
bisschen um mich kümmern um die samira
für man das bett aufbauen also brauchst
du auf und ich helfe dir und einfach
alles richten die klinik tasche richten
dass ich da einfach mal einen freien
kopf habe und mich einfach vorbereiten
kann
und ja und vielleicht könnt ihr in dem
zug einfach mal ein paar vorschläge
machen also da ich jetzt nächste woche
das letzte materien werde an ein zwei
tagen könnt ihr euch ja mal gerne
überlegen was würdet ihr gern noch sehen
er was zum kochen er auch zum backen was
süßes was herzhaftes äußert einfach eure
wünsche und ich schauten einfach was
sich davon umsetzen kann
nachgemacht videoweb cool
ja ich weiß schon was du willst
unbedingt das kinderparadies wahnsinn
also wenn ihr das auch möchte
kinderparadies so mach ich es gerne nach
als nachgemacht
dann eine frage die hat mich sehr
verwirrt denn die kam von meinem mann
murat auf schulkinder bei instagram
account moment ihr sowieso was du da
fragen ein wie kommt morath mit der
schwangerschaft klagen ich hab ja auch
schon geredet weil ja dass mich schon
gerettet ich war ja ich folge dir ja wir
kommen mit damit klar also mit muss
eigentlich nur selber die frage
beantworten
die dargestellte frau vor gericht klar
komme nichts für dich schon so bittel
nebenher gerne schwanger und natürlich
nehme es geht halt mit und zeigt ihr die
welt zeigt samira die welt hat übrigens
auch gesagt da ist dann zeigt er die
welt sah ich immer wieder gesagt mehr
raus nicht zeigt samira mal die welt
also mit samir ives übrigens
mittlerweile ist so sie spricht gerne
über ihre kleine schwester ohne über die
bevorstehende geburt und so weiter und
aber eins ist uns aufgefallen die bin
halt immer mal kuscheln adamek schon so
ein abend zum beispiel oder nacht kommt
sie halt gern zu uns ins bett da müssen
auch immer aufpassen
neulich war es nämlich so also die
kleine ella im bauch wenn man sehr
festgelegt auf den namen ella die
strampelt er ziemlich viel wurde auch
gefragt also es kann man echt nicht mehr
als strampeln bezahlen
alles also der bauch verformt sich in
alle möglichen richtungen und tut
mittlerweile auch echt weh weil ich
anscheinend auch ziemlich wenig
fruchtwasser noch habe und dann merkt
altes kind noch mehr weil hat alles nur
noch aus kind besteht und dann strampelt
die von innen und ich liege auf der
seite und dann kommt voll der tritt von
samira in meinem bauch also es war schon
heftig als man macht das war echt ja
goutiert sich dann auch von den schulden
ja das tut mir leid
na ja auf jeden fall wenn sie jetzt zum
kuscheln kommt legt sie sich immer mit
dem rad mit zimmermann hat wesen schon
kann alle zufügen
das wird sich schon wieder einspielen
und einpendeln
schläft in einem eigenen zimmer dann kam
noch die frage was fällt dir
mittlerweile schwärmen als habe es vor
allem morath schon erzählt ich kann zum
beispiel keine sorgen mehr im stehen
anziehen
vielleicht einfach unfalls schwer also
die schwerkraft na ja auf jeden fall
kann ich nicht mehr lange stehen und das
gemütliche herz ich kann mich nicht mehr
gemütlich hinsetzen oder liegen es ist
einfach ungemütlich im moment und ich
versuche mir halt immer daheim habe ich
auch immer die bequemsten klamotten an
als immer eine jogginghose und ein
weißes t shirt und dann lege ich mich
dann irgendwie auf die couch und
versuchten hat gemütlich zu machen mit
irgendwelchen kissen und so weiter habe
alles okay die frage wie ernähre dich im
moment ich ernähre mich immer noch wie
vor ein paar wochen auch also auch wie
vor der schwangerschaft ich erinnere
mich ja sowieso denke ich recht
ausgewogen und trinkt hat relativ viel
immer drei liter am tag da habe ich ja
diese app auf dem handy und erinnert
mich immer dran und samira erinnert mich
daran weil sie immer auf die abdrücken
will und von daher als ich erst gerne
obst und gemüse weiterhin unterhalt und
jetzt auf vorletzten frage und es hat
mich echt gewundert dass das die frage
jetzt erst kommt ich glaube ihr traut
mir das einfach nicht so und zwar die
frage rauchst du bzw hast du vor dass
bis vor der schwangerschaft geraucht
auf der kola ich glaube jeder weiß dass
ich nichtraucher bin und ich glaube man
traut es mir auch gar nicht so keine
ahnung also ich finde das schon ziemlich
gesundheitsbewusst und muss sagen ich
habe auch noch nie geraucht ich hatte
zwar immer freundinnen die geraucht
haben und ich hätte auch als teenie
bestimmt irgendwann mal angefangen aber
ich habe einfach mein papa irgendwann
mal das versprechen gegeben dass ich
niemals rauchen wird und hat er gesagt
das hat schon das hat jeder von deinen
geschwistern gesagt und alle haben
angefangen zu rauchen
und ich habe das nicht versprechen dass
ich auch nicht und zwar mein versprechen
und ich hab's nicht gemacht und
mittlerweile bin ich natürlich froh drum
weil rauchen schadet einfach und um aufs
thema zu kommen brauchen während der
schwangerschaft finde ich für mich
persönlich das schlimmste was
neben alkohol in der schwangerschaft
weil du einfach dadurch deinem kind
schade ist und es gibt so viele mütter
hat die halt vorher rauchen und dann
während schwangerschaft und während der
stillzeit nicht rauchen und irgendwann
dann wieder anfangen aber das hat er
dann die eigene entscheidung ist schade
weil es sich für euch auch schädlich
aber zumindest haben sie dann das kind
und beschützen das kind ausgibt hat
genug frauen die auch während der
schwangerschaft rauchen und das finde
ich halt total schlimm und da kann mir
keiner sagen wenn ich jetzt sofort
aufhört dann hat das kind einen entzug
also kein arzt der welt würde zu dir
sagen gewöhnte das rauchen langsam ab
jeder arzt sagt egal wie viel du
geraucht höher sofort auf weil es ein
jeder zug startet dem kind und ich finde
es einfach unverantwortlich und es geht
gar nicht
also deswegen rauchen während der
schwangerschaft echt ein no go und auch
während der stillzeit ein no go
von daher seine geschwister aufgehört
stimmt braucht eigentlich auch keiner
mehr bei uns genau schaut ja ich finde
auch rauchen ist out also ich denke auch
dass nicht mehr so viele jugendliche ich
weiß es nicht aber ich finde auch
rauchen ist out also in meiner in meinem
umkreis rauchen auch nicht viele
ich will er das erste mal gemacht wenn
du anders sein wollte ich ja aber
heutzutage noch heute mal fernseh gucken
schon anders mit dem formalen sich also
ganz normal
da müsste schon anders herzliches tool
sein also ich denke das
gesundheitsbewusstsein kommt halt immer
mehr also ich denke auch dass immer
weniger junge leute zu fastfood greifen
werden weil sie einfach sagen he kommen
auch so dieses vegetarische veganer das
wird immer mehr kommen und ich denke das
ist einfach wieder meine person kann man
ja das ist die sache aber ernährung
man sagt ja auch dass das fleisch ist es
neue rauchen vor der tür stehen aber ich
will das nicht so extrem
es wird bewusst wenn man meister einmal
im jahr wird bewusster und natürlich ich
esse gerne fleisch mehr fleisch ist der
erstes halb unfertig eben ja also das zu
dem thema und murat jetzt eine frage
tätig betrifft lässt
frage hat moral meeres geburt geweint
antwort sie selber also ich hab jetzt
nicht direkt bei der geburt geweint ich
habe das erste mal gemacht
das erste mal ich geweint als das
kindergeld kam das ist ein bisschen
stimmt doch gar nicht natürlich während
der gebürtiger bei sally natürlich und
steht er hat geweint und man hat auch
gewalttätig geworden ich war zu kaputt
zum weinen
na ja das ist wahr es war kein schluss
zu es war auch kein wimmern
das war halt eine träne eine
männer-trainer ja ja so wie ich denk
seiner geburt ist ziemlich emotional und
vor allem für die außenstehenden also
ich selber habe es zwar auch als
emotional empfunden aber war er mit
meinen kräften beschäftigten beim kind
mit mir selber aber der morath der war
schon als du heute schon und emotionalen
ausbruch hatte ich nicht sagen man
musste auch als man unterschreiben wenn
man im kreißsaal dabei sein will muss
anders schreiben dass er nachher für
psychische schäden die verantwortungen
das ist ganz wichtig weiter was ich bei
der geburt buch ich war bei meinem kopf
ja natürlich
ja was soll ich sonst seien ja ich hab
mein kostüm knopfes gegessen oder nein
ich weiß aber noch als ich die venen
hatte da saß da mit seiner zeitschrift
ja das war unsere vater kind zeitung
naja ich vorbild dazu händchenhalten und
na ja auf jeden fall war die fragen die
am meisten gestellt wurden aber ganz
kurz ich finde wenn man als echt toll
wenn man dabei ist und auch den schmerz
leid noch das schöne als vater sieht
aber ich finde halt wenn wir das nicht
um ich weiß es nicht aber ich will jetzt
auch keine mit vorwurf man dennoch dabei
sein ich hab dich ja auch nichts
gezwungen wir haben als am anfang hatten
wir so während der schwangerschaft
wesentlich höher
willst du mit dabei sein oder netten hat
er erst sagt erkannt dass nur da kann es
nicht mit ansehen war ich natürlich
schon ziemlich enttäuscht weil immerhin
ist es unser gemeinsames kind und als
frau wünscht man sich natürlich dass der
mann mit dabei ist mein bruder weiß ich
dass die frau
eine frau hat ihn bei der geburt da wird
es sagen beleidigt aber auf übelste
weise das so gar nicht auffällt schmeißt
ihn raus nimmt sie ihn freiwillig raus
genau
ja das war schon heftig wahrscheinlich
angst gemacht aber ich war ja es gibt
frauen die ihren mann beleidigt bgh das
ist ganz heftig macht man da auch nicht
aber es ist halt ist schmerz da kommt da
nicht der arzt da kommt der exorzist und
ja aber auch nicht sagt wenn man nicht
dabei sein will
finde ich auch darf man die jeder
denjenigen ne zwingen weil kann hat auch
schon
es ist wirklich so also wenn der mann
sieht es echt mit anguckt dann kann ein
echter psychische schäden davon tragen
ich weiß kann auch sich auf die
partnerschaft hat auswirkungen auf die
beziehung war also für mich persönlich
war es im kreis seien nicht das
schwimmen das schlimme war für mich
wohin lachkrampf gekriegt dass die juden
die wurz vorbereitungskursen krieg mit
der feuerwehr haben wir ja nicht normal
unsere freundin fragen wie es bei etwa
weil wir jetzt keinen gemacht
bewusst am ersten blick aber macht mit
beim ersten mal auf ihn also näher als
man muss es nicht machen und uns wieder
verplappert
auf jeden fall einzig noch eingefangen
ich wurde nämlich gefragt was ich denn
an tipps weitergeben könnte für frauen
die angst vor der geburt haben und ich
habe gesagt ich habe keine angst es ist
jetzt mehr so viel aufregung und ich
hatte auch fonds amiras geburt keine
angst ihr müsst euch einfach mal
vorstellen
zuerst mal seid ihr nicht die erste
nicht die letzte frau auf der welt den
kind kriegt ich halt so und vor allen
dingen hat mir sehr geholfen dass ich
bei jeder wählt die halt kam und die
wirklich schmerzhaft war einfach gedacht
habe okay jetzt habe ich eine weg also
man konnte so abhaken und dann habe ich
mich sogar auf die nächste wege freut
weil ich wusste jedem e die ich jetzt
habe ich eine weniger von daher so kam
bei mir so das positive denken es ist
auch evolution evolutionstechnisch so
bedingt dass die frau eigentlich
schmerzen bei der geburt vergisst
absoluten ich hab sie nicht mal gelesen
wir sagen auch viele geschäfte also ich
hab sehr kurz nach der geburt absolut
nicht vergessen auch ein halbes jahr
später nicht ich weiß auch heute wie
schmerzhaft das war ich weiß noch nicht
mehr wie schmerzhaft also ich weiß es
war sehr schmerzhaft und ich hab mir
zwischendurch echt gewünscht was habe
ich gern was versteht da angetan aber
trotzdem denkst du dir okay das kind ist
mir mehr wert wie jetzt der schmerz den
ich ertragen muss du also von daher ja
aber sieht wahrscheinlich jede frau auch
anders aber ich bin da sehr positiv
deswegen habt keine angst vor geburten
und wenn ihr während der schwangerschaft
sowieso keine komplikationen hatte wird
auch da denke ich alles gut laufen und
wenn ihr komplikationen hatte
es ist einfach so ihr werdet überstehen
und ja denkt einfach immer positiv und
habe keine angst weil ich finde dass man
dann halt er den stress kommt und dann
vielleicht ja in panik gerät und so
weiter und nehmt euch eine person mit
eures vertrauens weil jeder der mama
dabei und macht das war cool
das fand ich nicht also meine mama hat
sich dabei aber für sie war sehr schwer
weil eine mama denke ich meine mama hat
fünf kinder gekriegt auf natürlichem weg
und ich habe ihr das land angesehen dass
sie halt gerade richtig mit mir mit
leidet und mamas verstehen deshalb daher
also ist nicht cool also wirklich
mehrmals man reingeht und dann die
mutter dabei also nicht die also die
mutter der euch die schwiegermutter okay
ich würde sagen jetzt noch mal schluss
auf jeden fall gibt es das nächste mal
dann videos zur meiner erstausstattung
da würde ich euch ein paar tipps geben
aus meiner sicht was braucht man was
braucht man nicht was ist unnötig wie
kann man geld sparen zum beispiel auch
wird euch zeigen was ich in meiner
klinik tasche einpacken und wenn ihr
möchtet
gerne auch wie ich zum beispiel bisserl
zimmer einrichten und die wohnung
einrichten ja ich weiß aber nicht ob mir
ist nicht so alles schaffen ab morgen
kommt übrigen ist ein cooles video und
morgen kommt übrigens eine richtig tolle
motiv torte und damals richtig von mir
gegeben als ist ein ganz anderes video
als bisher
ich mache ein trailer rein nach diesem
video ja so eine kleine vorschau alles
klar
aber eigentlich die fragen von
wirtschaft komme ich nun meinen spruch
die ganze ja okay ich lass doch mich
vorliegt
nein aber du kannst meine schrift jetzt
wahrscheinlich einfach die kamera machen
durch klatschen
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt